the idea was had the bomb gone off they
would all
congregate here they would shut down
inside here they had enough
oil in the tanks to run the generators
for 35
days deep under the devon countryside
there is a piece of cold war history
originally built in 1941 as a world war
ii radar station it was converted in the
50s
its purpose to house 250 government
staff
in the event of a soviet nuclear attack
the place was highly secure there were
people on the wardens on the gate all
the time
there were people here 24 hours a day
and it was kept fully
operational in as much that all the
systems were kept so that they could be
brought into use should the bomb have
something have gone off
hope cove bunker was on standby right up
until the 1990s
the vast labyrinth of secure rooms still
contain reminders of the past
and how it would have played a vital
role in the event of a nuclear war
it is from these radio rooms that
emergency broadcasts would have been
transmitted from
fully soundproofed it is from in here
that the public
would have received the latest
information this is one of the
operational maps that would have been
used
in the 1960s 70s and 80s
with war maps still hanging this grade
two listed bunker
has now gone on sale to the public we've
had people that have looked at it as
cheese storage wine storage a
community sort of area so you rent out
different rooms to
our exhibitions dance classes few people
have had the sort of hotel ideas as well
this huge bunker comes with dozens of
bathrooms and
56 bedrooms but also
a possible ghost lots of old raf
people have come back to have a have a
visit
and one of them a couple of them
actually told me about the
wartime pilot that used to come up the
steps here
um and they particularly heard his um
flying boots
sort of flapping and knocking and stuff
and he would have a shake of the gate
that used to be there and then and then
disappear back down
ghost or not the bunker is for sale for
435
000 pounds dan whitehead sky news in
sulcum
devon